[Musique]
notre débat ce soir pour conclure cette
belle semaine sous le thème de la
frénésie immobilière
faut-il intervenir pour calmer le marché
en surchauffe quels changements
réglementaires seraient susceptibles de
freiner la hausse des prix de mieux
protéger les acheteurs les propriétaires
de résidences on a parlé avec marc henri
arnauld à directeur général
l'association des consommateurs pour la
qualité dans la construction et denis
doucet porte parole chez multi prêts
hypothèques bonsoir à tous les deux
bonsoir
alors on va essayer de mettre cartes sur
table en commençant être vous de ceux
qui croient que le marché immobilier du
québec va se replacer naturellement où
il faut agir
monsieur doucet moi je pense que le
marché va se rappeler ce n'est pas la
première occasion où ce genre de
situation se produit ça s'est produit
dans les années 90 dans les années au
début des années 2000 et le problème
qu'ont actuellement c'est qu'il manque
d'offre sur le marché c'est à dire que
peu de gens qui mettent leur maison à
vendre et le nombre d'acheteurs
potentiels n'a pas réduit ce qui crée de
la surenchère
parce que souvent on se retrouve avec
des offres multiples sur la même
propriété qui ça crée une hausse de prix
donc ce que je comprends c'est que la
théorie c'est qu'avec la hausse future
des taux d'intérêt ou encore pour
raisons plusieurs facteurs ça va se
replacer tout seul lorsque la pandémie
sera réglée et que les gens auront moins
peur d'aborder visite chez eux déjà ça
sera un facteur qui va aider pour le
moment 18 on a vu le en mars 2020
qu'entre le gouvernement annoncée mais
ton de m québec sur pause eu de plus gm
plusieurs propriétés qui ont été retirés
du marché parce que les jeunes mamans il
y avait la crainte lui d'avoir déjà des
étrangers qui venaient jeter jeu et
depuis ce temps là ça ne jamais ça s'est
jamais rétabli jusqu'à maintenant mais
avec ce que le gouvernement nous dit que
la vaccination tout ça on peut espérer
que sous peu on va recommencer avoir
peut-être une offre sur le marché qui
soit un peu plus importante que ce qu'on
a actuellement monsieur harnois vous
pensé la même chose que ça va se
replacer tout seul en raison plusieurs
facteurs ou est-ce qu'il faut intervenir
a dit oui et non on conteste
une conjoncture qui pousse les prix à la
hausse actuellement et qui probablement
deux parties la surchauffe immobilière
qui va se régler un peu tout seul mais
ça change rien au fait que la surchauffe
exposé des lacunes dans notre système
immobilier au québec et que c'est tout à
fait le rôle gouvernement d'agir pour
corriger ces lacunes qui sont exposés
par la surchauffe immobilière puis pour
amoindrir le choc sur les ménages quand
vous parlez de lacunes je vous entends
vous vous faites référence un phénomène
qu'on soulignait beaucoup d'observateurs
même le patron de la banque nationale
louis vachon qui disait les enchères
opaque
lorsqu'il dit aux surenchères plusieurs
offres sur une même habitation il
faudrait que ça change vous êtes de
settat dit monsieur harnois oui oui
certainement c'est sûr que bon les
études se contredisent à savoir l'effet
que ça va avoir ou pas sur les prix mais
il n'en reste pas moins qu'ils que ça
manque de transparence et que si les
gens avaient accès aux eaux différentes
contre off ça pourrait assainir le
marché immobilier ça pourrait permettre
aux gens prendre des décisions qui se
base sur les faits et non pas sur
l'hypothétique contre-offre et puis on
va arrêter de jouer
l'atuge pas tout à fait d'accord parce
que fait faire des offres ouvertes ça
vous provoquez des enquêtes et son
talent aux courtiers immobiliers
actuellement quand ils reçoivent
plusieurs aux offres la mail la plus
élevée n'est pas nécessairement la
meilleure chacun évalue sa possibilité
peut-être naturellement parce que
plusieurs offres les gens essaient
d'aller au delà de la du prix demandé
pour essayer de convaincre l'acheteur le
vendeur de lors de leur vendre la
propriété mais c'est ce phénomène leur
s'est fait parce qu'il ya de l'émotion
acheter une propriété surtout quand
c'est dès les premières propriétés c'est
un rêve puis les gens un moment donné
perdre de vue la rationalité qui devrait
avoir la rationalité financière son voeu
le budgétaire qui devrait avoir qu'un
qui décide de proposer un cri pour une
maison à ce genre de phénomène dont on
voit pas son nom commercial passe dans
le commercial et calculs et les
chef marche c'est correct si ça marche
pas on débarque
oui mais je suis dit c'est par exemple
si les enchères étaient transparents et
conserver qu'une offre et 2 par exemple
500 milles de là elle sachant on peut
offrir 500 dollars de plus au lieu de
spéculer et offrir 5000 $ de plus pensez
pas que ça permettrait de freiner la
hausse des prix mais ce que je vous dis
c'est que si les gens le cvc qui va en
voie de la relance celui qui a offert
500 voir offrir 1 500 de plus 500 de
plus et ça va continuer quand comme un
an quand son regard d'un an quand les
gens entendent le prix de l'autre si
émotionnellement ils le veulent mais ils
vont remettre un petit peu plus un petit
peu plus un peu plus que ça vaut face à
va créer plusieurs surenchère mais
pourrait arriver selon - essentiellement
au même résultat peut-être pire encore
parce que comme je dis les gens on voit
aussi quand les gens demandent un prêt
une portion des motions là dedans ils
veulent avoir la propriété puis sont
prêts à y perdre de vue la rationalité
qui devrait avoir des points donc il ya
des acheteurs qui offre plus de manière
pas toujours rationnels et qui demandent
moins aussi de manière peut-être pas
toujours rationnels qui font des
concessions en fait sur par exemple la
garantie légale
est ce que c'est une bonne idée de faire
ça non c'est l'humain peut absolument
pas et là dessus je crois que moi
monsieur si on mettrait d'accord que ça
soit la garantie légale que ce soit
l'inspection ou pire les deux en même
temps c'est très très dangereux il va
avoir des lendemains difficiles pour
certains qu'est ce que ça peut avoir
comme si du côté de l'inspection est
évidemment que la plupart des gens sont
pas des spécialistes du bâtiment et
c'est le rôle de l'inspecteur d'être
leurs yeux pour voir tout ce qui est
apparent quand on achète un bâtiment et
quand on achète sans inspection on prend
un gros risque de se retrouver avec des
vis
davies qui pour un inspecteur était
apparent et pour lesquels ça va être
difficile de poursuivre par la suite la
ministre
andré la forêt justement a fait
connaître son intention de rendre les
inspections obligatoires pour les
bâtiments de plus de 25 ans qu'est ce
que vous en pensez monsieur doucet
c'est tout à fait c'est une très bonne
idée
c'est sûr que le gouvernement
vrai aussi jumelé à ce peut-être un
encadrement beaucoup plus sérieux pour
les inspecteurs parce qu'aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut se déclarer
inspecteur puis commencer à faire des
inspections même s'il connaît perso il
ya des associations qui existent mais il
ya pas une obligation d'avoir fait de la
formation ou d'avoir un certificat
quelconque halle qui autorise à le faire
mais moi je pense que surtout les
propriétés qui ont 25 ans il y en a qui
ont été bien entretenu il y en europe
c'est mettons ça a été laissée un peu
ours a manqué d'amour c'est ce qu'on
utilise normalement comme terme
mais ce que ça veut dire c'est que le
nouvel acheteur peut se retrouver avec
des problèmes très sérieux à court terme
et des problèmes qui avaient sous-estimé
ou peut-être même pas réalisé parce que
dieu il n'y avait pas tout à fait
d'inspection en plus oui bon ça c'est
pour les habitations existantes vous
avez une préoccupation monsieur harnois
concernant les acheteurs de maisons
neuves qui se retrouvent avec des
retards de livraison des augmentations
prévues parfois ça coûte très très cher
soit phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur en
ce moment oui mais nous on depuis depuis
février qu'on reçoit beaucoup de
dénonciation de code de non respect du
contrat préliminaire par des
entrepreneurs
ça vient de plein de façons différentes
le met essentiellement on parle de gens
qui ont signé pour acheter une maison
neuve et que pas très longtemps avant de
passer chez le notaire l'entrepreneur
les avertis qu'aux finalement ça va
coûter plus cher que ce qui a été
convenu dans certains cas il ya une
clause au contrat qu'il permet mais dans
la majorité des cas qu'on nous dénonce
il n'y a pas de clause d'augmentation
des prix et est donc la plupart du temps
par de quelque chose qui peut légal et
donc ça devrait être mieux encadrées
mieux superviser et les consommateurs
font appel à des organisations comme la
vôtre pour faire valoir leurs droits on
doit s'arrêter là-dessus messieurs mais
je pense qu'on ne peut pas trancher le
débat est toujours entier on va pouvoir
continuer d'en débattre
je remercie pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh